Speaker 1: All right. I want to start today with
a little data, some numbers. One often repeated
claim about gun violence in the United States
is the gun violence is a problem in so-called
Democrat cities with the strictest gun laws in the
country. And there are sort of two claims that the
right loves to make that are implicit in that one.
The problems with gun violence are in places that
try to restrict guns, meaning restrictive gun laws
increase violence and murder. And the second claim
is the most violent places are the places run by
Democrats. I put together data in a few different
ways and we're going to look at it. But the most
important I mean, before even looking at the data,
one of the things you have to remember is that
in general, there is more crime in more densely
populated areas. The more densely populated areas
tend to be places where people on the left tend to
live. But the truth is that the more violent
cities and the least violent cities are all
mostly run by Democrats because Democrats prefer
to live in cities, whereas Republicans prefer to
live in rural areas, generally speaking. So one
of the things you first have to think about is
what does the country look like before we even
can make any causal claims? But that being said,
let's take a look at some of this data. So what
I did was I took the where am I here? I took the.
Here we go. I took the most the 65 cities with the
highest murder rates in the country, and that's
along the left. And you can find this data.
And those are the cities that I have listed.
And then we looked at who is the mayor of those
cities and are they a Democrat or a Republican?
And then at the county level, was that a
Biden county or a Trump County in 2020?
And then at the state level, was that a Trump
state or a Biden state in 2020? Now, I have to
tell you, even doing this is a little fraught
because there are certain states, Virginia,
a bunch of these cities are in Virginia in 2020,
Biden won, but sometimes Republicans win Virginia.
So some of these states are question marks. Ohio
is a state that sometimes flips. Florida is a
state that sometimes slips. But there is a trend
here that is very clear. The cities with the most
the highest murder rates at the city level, it's
mostly Democratic mayors. Now, we would expect
that that makes perfect sense. Cities tend to be
run by Democrats. If we looked at a list of the
cities with the least gun violence, you would also
see that they're mostly run by Democrats. Cities
often make up the entire county in which they
are or close to it. In New York City, actually,
there's the city includes multiple counties,
Brooklyn and Kings County, whereas Manhattan.
Okay. Some people sort of understand that. But
generally speaking, you would assume that the
county would be similar to the city in that cities
and counties often are the same size or very close
to it. And most of the counties that contain these
cities were Biden counties. Well, is that a big
revelation about gun violence? Not really. Because
if you look at the entire map of the United States
by county, we know that cities tend to vote for
Democrats and all the other counties tend to vote
for Republicans typically. So cities on the most
dangerous list and cities on the least dangerous
list would all be on the add on would be run by
would be Democratic counties. And then lastly,
you look at the state level and
when you look at the state level,
you see that there's a lot of red there. A lot,
a lot, a lot of red. Trump states that Trump won.
And when we want to draw a causal relationship,
one of the questions we have to ask is whether
gun policy tends to be set at the city, county or
state level, and it's mostly at the state level.
So if we understand most of the murders will
be where there is more population density,
but the gun laws are mostly going
to be set at the state level.
You have to ask, well, does Saint Louis have a
lot of murders because the mayor is a Democrat?
Or because it's a red state with red state gun
laws. I'm not pretending that the answer in all
cases is one or the other. But if we understand
that it's mostly states that determine gun policy,
although there are some cities that will go
above and beyond, that's absolutely the case.
And we understand that at the base rate, Democrats
tend to live more in cities than Republicans.
And we understand that even if you're in Chicago,
Chicago's gun laws, if you can drive into Indiana
at the end of the day, don't really impact your
ability to get a gun very much unless there's a
cohesive effort. This repeated talking point of
gun violence is a Democrat city problem. Very
quickly falls apart. Now I am totally open to
exploring other explanations. Let let me give
you another one. We can also accurately say
gun violence seems to be a red state problem.
But there as well, I'm willing to say maybe access
to mental health is part of it. We've got to deal
with the guns, but maybe mental health is
part of it. But it's the red states that
fund mental health services less than blue
states. We looked at that earlier this week.
It's the red states like Texas that
have governors like Greg Abbott,
who recently voted against more funding for mental
health treatment. So I say let's look at all of
these things, but we have to include guns in that.
And we have to understand Democrat city problem
is not accurate and there's no particular reason
to look at cities rather than states. When you
look at states, it's a red state problem. If you
look at cities, it's a Democrat problem only in
the sense that most cities are run by Democrats,
the really safe ones and the unsafe ones. So
I think you get the picture. We're
going to continue following up on this.